because of its grown-up characters
themes and complex mythology
1999's the mummy provides plenty of
moments that adults will be thinking
about
long after the kids in the room have
moved on to the next thing
in the film's prologue the magi warrior
artist bae
explains that anak su namoon was the
pharaoh's mistress and it was forbidden
for any other man to touch her
to make this point anaksu namoon wore
very little clothes
and was instead covered in an elaborate
body paint design that ran over most of
her body
when her secret lover the high priest
imotep touched her in a moment of
passion
he smeared the paint it's that smudge
that reveals her betrayal to the pharaoh
the smudged body paint is a clever
shorthand that lets the audience in on
the moment without over explaining
it but any adult who's ever put on
makeup body paint or even a halloween
costume
has to wonder why that's the look the
pharaoh settled on it certainly let him
know that someone touched his mistress
but it seems like anaksu namoon could
have just as easily smeared the paint by
bumping into a wall
or laying down for a nap plus waking up
and applying all of that paint
every day must have been the worst
morning routine ever no wonder a naksu
namoon went looking for another man
after the murder of the pharaoh in enoch
su namoon's death
imotep launched a plan to resurrect his
beloved that involved a forbidden ritual
at hammonoptra the city of the dead
imotep dared the god's anger by going
deep into the city
where he took the black book of the dead
from its holy resting place
unfortunately the pharaoh's bodyguards
followed imotep
captured him and subjected him to the
humdai a curse
so cruel that the egyptians had never
performed it before
after being mummified alive and entombed
in a sarcophagus filled with scarab
beetles
cursed to remain the undead for all of
eternity imotep's body was buried in
hamanoptra
then a group of warriors called the magi
begin their millennia-long
effort to watch over the city they knew
that if the high priest ever returned he
would become an all-powerful being that
could destroy the world
it begs the question why did the ancient
egyptians need to use that particular
curse if it had such potentially
devastating consequences
why not just mummify him alive like they
did with the rest of his priests
it makes sense that imotep be punished
for his crimes but this insane curse
feels like an unnecessary risk
evelyn carnahan and her brother jonathan
are the descendants of great explorers
and their adventure begins when jonathan
unknowingly steals the map to
hammonoptra from explorer rick o'connell
while investigating it evie's boss burns
a part of the map
this convinces evie that they need
rick's guidance if they ever hope to
find the lost city
she decides to spring rick from prison
with a little bit of bribery aimed at
the warden
if you cut him down we will give you 10
50 20 430
25 once released the small band of
explorers head off in a race against a
group of treasure hunters who also want
to discover the hidden egyptian city of
the dead
the journey is more than a bit bumpy
after the riverboat catches fire and
sinks
the gang takes the camels to make the
rest of the trip eventually they find
themselves on a desert plain
looking at the sunrise it's then that
rick informs the group that they have to
wait for the sun to hit an exact point
in the sky
before the location of hamanoptra is
revealed to them the treasure hunters
have caught up to them at this point
and as the city is revealed it becomes a
race to see which group reaches their
destination first
the problem here is that rick shouldn't
need the sun to show him the way to
haminoptra
he's been there before after all if he
knew where to stand for the sun to
reveal the city
there's a good chance he could have
navigated the rest of the way simply by
memory
it would have removed the need for a
race but then again the race is a pretty
great set piece for the movie
over the course of the mummy the film
lays out an elaborate mythology for the
fabled city of hamanoptra
though many believe it's only a myth
various scholars have done research on
it and the film establishes clearly that
the city is a very real and very haunted
place
in fact the magi have spent millennia
guarding it and trying to keep it secret
despite the fact that not everyone in
the movie believes in hamanoptra
a lot of people still seem to have a
fairly easy time getting to it
a massive battle erupts amongst its
ruins near the beginning of the movie
and two expeditions travel back to its
location years later
evie talks frequently about its layout
and rick notes that tales of hamonoptra
are so pervasive that his military unit
defied orders to march to egypt from
libya to look for it
so while the medjay are rather reactive
once people make it to hamanoptra
maybe they should start branching out
into more proactive efforts to keep
legends of the city a little more tamped
down
it might make their job easier though it
draws inspiration from historical
concepts like mummies and the egyptian
concept of the afterlife
and it also mentions historical figures
like seti the first
the mummy is firmly based in the world
of fiction it's a big
fun fantasy horror adventure which
allows it to take a lot of liberties
even with biblical history one of the
warnings given by the magi about the
horrible fate that would befall the
world should imotep rise from the dead
is that he could bring the return of the
plagues to
egypt and sure enough as soon as he's
back things like swarms of locusts and
fountains of blood start to plague the
world once more
despite imotep referencing the language
of the slaves when he hears benny
speaking hebrew there aren't any
biblical references in the movie
yet the plagues in question are
specifically drawn from the book of
exodus
so why does imotep get to use the
plagues that god devised to torment the
egyptians
it's probably because these days the
plagues are more associated with egypt
in general
as opposed to the specific story of
moses freeing his people from the
oppression of the pharaoh
the plot of the mummy requires some very
specific events to take place for it to
make sense
some of these events rely on ancient
egyptian rituals that many of the
characters must discover and then
perform correctly
in fact the climax of the movie involves
evie rick
and jonathan battling the all-powerful
imotep and relies on the recital of
spells from a pair of mystical books
the book of the dead contains spells
needed to resurrect people
and the book of ammun rock contains the
spells that allow someone to command the
dead
or render the undead mortal once again
both of these ancient tomes are
presented as extremely dangerous in the
wrong hands
and they even require a special key that
unlocks the books
and allows them to be opened
unfortunately locking the books doesn't
seem to prevent some characters from
using them
near the end of the film jonathan gets
hold of the book of ahmanra
and manages to command a group of mummy
soldiers by reading an
inscription on the cover apparently you
don't need to understand what you're
reading to make the spells work
which increases the danger posed by them
combined with the fact that some of the
spells are written right on the cover of
the books
it gives the impression that the
egyptians who wrote these volumes
probably should have taken a little more
care before publishing
or at the very least devised a more
foolproof security system
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite monster movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one